what was it MSNBC or NBC uh suspended
their own reporter for accidentally
telling the truth about that story rip
he's still gone he's still suspended to
tell the truth on a mainstream don't do
it don't do it guys could you imagine
like you're a reporter and you get an
email it's like come to the come to HR
and they're like
yeah um Miguel we have troubling
reporting coming in from co-workers did
you tell the truth on air well I I I did
I'm sorry you know but thank you for
being honest or or not you're suspended
it's like look it specifically says on
line four of your contract that you're
not supposed to tell the truth so you're
gonna have to get fired sorry sorry my
guy they like they throw they have like
a sarlacc pit and they're like let me
just push him in dude that's right media
it's like how uh you know Amy Roebuck is
currently in the news right now for
having an affair with one of her
co-hosts but she wasn't in the news back
in what two years ago when she knew
about Jeffrey Epstein and kind of just
overlooked it